for many the new year symbolizes a fresh
start and a time to set resolutions and
over the next few months many gyms and
studios see an influx of people who
want to get fit eight news now reporter
kate houston spoke to the owner of a
local meal prep business
about the importance of nutrition when
it comes to achieving your goals
it's very important to plan ahead and
that's what we're here for
andrew portergalidad is the head chef
and owner of the good life meal prep
a las vegas business offering healthy
cooked meals that are delivered to a
customer on a weekly basis
they don't have to think about it it's
peace of mind they have a
healthy nutritious balanced meal
ready to go in the refrigerator when the
day gets busy
like clockwork protogallidad says he
always sees a bump in sales the week
after new year's
when it comes to fitness resolutions
nutrition is just as essential as
hitting the gym
as far as tackling exercise goals
running goals
lifting goals you're going to need that
extra nutrition so
it's important to stay on top of all
that while meal prep is great for those
solely focusing on fitness
puerto gallidad adds that this model is
just as helpful for busy moms and dads
trying to balance their health and
taking care of their kids
sometimes when you're cooking for other
people and taking care of other people
you just need a little help
at the end of the day or in the middle
of the day someone
that has your back and is going to take
care of you as many head into the new
year with a focus on wellness
puerto gallidad says it's important to
stay consistent both in the gym
and the kitchen it's important that when
you're setting your goals
you have a plan of attack and then you
stick to those kate houston
8 news now the good life team rotates
its menu based on what's in season the
goal of each meal is to be balanced and
familiar to most customers
there are options for all ages including
kids as well